welcome to booze science where the goal
is better drinking through chemistry
now most bartenders use a lot of science
to make the perfect cocktail whether
they know it or not but you can actually
use some of that same science to make
perfect drinks at home today on booze
science nice to learn more about it I
went to an expert at one of my favorite
bars the interval of the long nail this
is the person who runs it Jen Kylie oh
hi Jen hi thanks for doing this
it's an incredible space of beautiful
Bryant you know ever-changing artwork
behind the bar incredible glass work
everywhere and some of the best
cocktails that you'll have in the city a
lot of the best cocktails are a little
bit like revenge in that they are best
served cold and it's a little true but
one of the reasons that I want to come
here is that you have a very controlled
process for thinking about temperature
yes your ice is going to be 32 degrees
Fahrenheit the fruit temperature
freezing but you can bring a cocktail
much colder than that and that's because
of the thermal energy that's expended as
the ice is melting in your cocktail
because the alcohol acts as antifreeze
mastering that melt can give you bar
level control over your drink not just
the temperature but also texture and
strength and taste think of it as a
dilution solution dilution is a is a
critical component of a cocktail most
cocktail recipes won't actually call for
water but they'll call for shaking or
stirring over ice so it's that dilution
that you're adding to the alcoholic
ingredients that kind of bring you know
unify all of all the flavors the
textures and that kind of stuff so we
measure dilution by measuring the
temperature as we store drinks down so
we have different temperatures that we
hit based on what the drink is what its
components are and how it is served so
that's interesting so so temperature
becomes the proxy for how much melt
water your cats correct yeah Jen showed
me how she makes some of the long now
spirits always during with the digital
thermometer for precision first she made
me a gorgeous Manhattan which she stirs
to exactly 32 degrees no need to go
lower as Manhattan's are nicely balanced
they don't need much leverage
yeah see it's good drink then Jen made
me an old-fashioned which is actually
pretty avant-garde at least when it
comes to the ice she stirs to 35 degrees
and then pours it into a glass has a
wedge of ice frozen into it in advance
it's not just a look though that does
look cool but there's a reason for it
too
a lot of ice nerds like to talk about
how a an ice sphere or an ice ball has
the least amount of surface area to it
but a flat plane has less than that so
it's a little bit it's a little bit
gimmicky but it's also like totally true
plus there's a certain pleasure in out
hurting the ice nerds yes yes absolutely
we'll see yeah it's beautiful
Thanks as neat as that trick is Jen's
next drink a gimlet variant that she
invented is where the science of super
cooling really kicks in a gimlet is
traditionally gin and lime cordial I
don't make a separate lime cordial but I
use the elements of lime cordial lime
zest lime juice and sugar it takes us
three days we clarify it this is super
fruity we need to bring it way down so I
use the temperature to gauge how much
dilution I'm putting in this drink Jen
stirs until the drink gets to 28 degrees
well below freezing that adds water
brings the percent of alcohol in the
drink down and you taste fruit instead
of booze yeah it's really it's really
wonderful thank you the lime is so
strong it's it's like biting into a on
summer but-but-but-but you can only get
it here I mean it's hydrated yes yes for
that gimlet you will have to come to the
interval but using a thermometer to to
measure dilution is a way to
consistently make delicious drinks when
you're at home it's really not it's not
very complicated it just requires a
thermometer and some patience sorry for
the pun in advance but it's really cool
I keep that appreciate absolutely
Oh